you know if you didn't know any better
you think this was a throwback episode
of around the horn
there it is
pleased to be joy another brother from
another j.a adande uh the esteemed
director of sports journalism for the
medal school at northwestern university
kind enough to take time out bro thanks
for thanks for falling through on the
first day of class so the professor's
taking a break yeah to chop it up with
us man so we figure we're talking about
the big ten right mike who better to go
to than somebody who's literally in the
big ten and bleeds northwestern that's
right you know aja i i know as a
professor you want the students to ask
some questions hey talk back to me so
i'm gonna ask you a question professor
you know this this news breaks today
that the season is gonna start in
october october 24th specifically
now what do you make of this because it
is a big time reversal from what we
heard in august do you think this is uh
is this a good thing
yeah one thing you know you have to
allow for the the changes in the
technology right um
as
you know this is a fluid situation and
it's different in different parts of the
country but sorry my phone having
technical issues here sorry but um uh
you know one one
so things have changed and i do think it
is a response to the pressure into the
negative response that they got from
from that initial statement i i do think
there's balancer my main concern is that
for example at northwest university
freshmen and sophomores are not allowed
on campus
so if half the undergraduate population
it's not deemed safe for them to be on
campus um how can you consider it safe
for the football team to gather in
practice and i understand they're going
to be tested at a higher level and
probably with much greater frequency
than the rest of the student body
population but if that's the case you
know how do you explain to the rest of
the students who are paying their heart
and money for tuition uh why the
football player can get some of the full
benefits of their college experience
while the rest of the student body can i
you know i have major issues with that
one of your one of your fellow uh
northwestern alums christine brennan uh
in usa today wrote about how she called
it the darkest day
in big ten history because the big ten
pretty much cave to the pressure that
we've been talking about um
anyone could argue if the big ten is
experienced worse but nonetheless she
was just really disappointed that the
big ten contrary to its reputation and
history and brand was not showing
leadership what was rather following the
crowd in this context i wonder it's your
first day back you obviously plugged
into all things big ten but specifically
how is it playing within the
northwestern community like what are
some of the administrators saying some
of the non-football or not athletic
department uh power brokers if you will
how are they all processing this
it is a little different because we're
not okay you know my my building isn't
open so so we're not communing to to
have these discussions so that that's
one of the ways it's different but but
i'll just say yes you know the fact that
we're not all in our campus buildings
while you know the the football office
that the new 300 million dollar football
facility is going to be occupied um
you know that that that shows how how
the parties are executed and you know
after watch when i say that our
president of the university is the
leader of this big ten council that's
been making the decisions um you know
and
so we certainly he's much more better
informed than any of us are he's heard
all the latest he's got the medical
details
i understand that and
i understand that
the basis of this decision i think
they've explained it better than they're
giving credit for but i think we need to
acknowledge why this is happening this
is something that is taking place
because of the financial implications
you know i've heard the numbers that we
stand to lose i'm not sure i'm liberty
at liberty to to disclose the exact
numbers that i've heard but um you know
it's obviously multiple millions of
dollars and so i think we need to
acknowledge why this is the reason that
this is taking place
and
the problem is to do so gets you into a
whole other discussion about fair
compensation of college athletes i think
going down this door
is taking college sports the ncaa the
places it's really not comfortable
having these discussions and not having
a resolution to this before they go
forward they're going to go ahead and
play before they they resolve some of
the long-standing issues uh that should
be addressed here
well you know what uh j.a uh i i'm not
going to ask you to disclose those
numbers that that that you have and we
don't but just reading from a forbes
article in 2019 just for example
so big ten gets a 66 million dollar base
payout
six million dollars that year for ohio
state's semifinal birth in the fiesta
bowl four million dollars for penn
state's birth in the cotton bowl and 40
million dollars for wisconsin's birth in
the rose bowl
so i mean
that's a lot i mean look at those
numbers those numbers stack up so it
clearly is about the money and as i said
i can't judge you
for making financial decisions we all
uh make financial decisions uh
to a degree look i mean that's just the
reality of it
but i'm just saying let's just be let's
be upfront about it you said one of your
concerns
is
that the college football players are
getting some
some privileges that the rest of the
student body is not are there any other
concerns with this decision that jump
out at you
yeah just the fact that we don't know
the long-term effects of catching the
disease even if you're asymptomatic
you know even if you're not hospitalized
directly as a result we don't know you
know the long-term impact this is going
to have on people's lungs and hearts
which are the two main areas but you
know the nervous system like this is a
brutal virus it can affect your brain
functions as well uh which you would
think you know for for college students
would be of utmost priority as well so
you know the fact that we don't know
what the long-term impact could be on
this we don't know for example will they
be covered uh you know what's the
liability for universities uh you know
has has that been established um you
know are they indemnified for in any
future potential lawsuits that could
occur as as a result of this is the
conference indemnified um you know i'm
not sure every single question has been
addressed um
initially my concern was that we were
asking students or athletes to take
greater risk than the rest of the
student body by asking them to play i
think now they've gotten to the point
where they can actually maybe make
the college athletes safer than the rest
of the student body but again i don't
think they should be safer i don't think
they should be subjected to any greater
risk than the rest of the student body
and you know i'm i'm i like aaron on the
side of caution mike i'm like you know
you say you're gonna be the last one to
get the vaccine you're gonna be the
second or last cause i'm gonna be the
last one i'm someone i don't even like
to get the latest when they update the
software on your on your phone i went to
like version 0.2 or 0.3 right i don't
even like the first to get the software
update on the phone so i'm not going to
be the first to get what will certainly
be the fastest vaccine ever brought to
market i'm not trying to be that guy
we're i wake up every morning to uh
update and i decline it i'm like nope
tell me tomorrow or no
i'm with you yeah yeah yeah you may have
like three or four i'll feel better
yeah
and not just the oh i'm sorry mike i
wasn't saying not just not just that
they not just that they aren't uh that
they might they might be
uh giving privileges that the rest of
the student body isn't getting they're
not in a bubble either in a lot of cases
like how many on how many campuses will
you be able to keep them separate from
the rest of the student body so as not
to be exposed to all these outbreaks